24 mars 1975. Mohamed Ali affronte Chuck Wepner,
un boxeur inconnu du grand public. Wepner s'est vu
offrir la chance d'affronter le champion du monde
en titre, lors d'un combat qui ne devait être,
pour Ali, qu'une simple formalité.
Wepner est donné perdant à 40 contre un
au cinquième round. Mais les choses ne vont
pas se dérouler exactement comme prévu...
Boxeur lent, à la technique laborieuse, Wepner est
dominé par le champion, qui joue avec lui comme
un chat avec une souris. Mais malgré les coups,
Wepner revient toujours à la charge, au grand dam
de Mohamed Ali qui s'agace des crochets derrière
la tête que lui assène son adversaire. Ali veut en finir. Le spectacle a assez duré. Seul problème : Wepner tient debout.
Le challenger n'a pas l'air décidé à abandonner, et s'offrira même le
luxe d'envoyer Ali au tapis devant un publicmédusé. Il faudra attendre le quinzième round,
dix-neuf secondes avant la cloche,
pour que Wepner s'incline. Enfin...
Dans les gradins, un spectateur observeattentivement la scène. Son nom ? Sylvester
Stallone. Ce soir-là, Sylvester rentrera chezlui et écrira le scénario d'un long-métrage qui
allait remporter trois oscars l'année suivante,
dont celui du meilleur film : "Rocky".
Rocky, c'est l'histoire de Robert Balboa, un
boxeur de Philadelphie auquel le destin va
offrir la chance de sa vie : combattre pour
le titre de champion du monde en affrontant
l'actuel détenteur du titre, Apollo Creed.
Creed est certain de l'emporter face à Balboa.
Et surtout, il sait que donner à un illustre
inconnu l'opportunité d'aller au titre lui
permettra d'accéder à la gloire médiatique.
Mais contrairement à Wepner, quand Rocky apprend
que Creed l'a désigné pour l'affronter, il refuse
le combat. Lui, le petit loubard de Philadelphie,
comment pourrait-il être à la hauteur
face au champion du monde ?
Rocky n'a pas d'ambition, si ce n'est
celle de conquérir le cœur d'Adrian,
la vendeuse de la boutique animalière qu'il tente
maladroitement de séduire jour après jour.
En conflit avec son entraîneur,
négligeant son hygiène de vie,
Rocky semblait décidé à passer à côté de son destin.
Mais Adrian lui redonnera le goût du défi,
et surtout, la confiance qui lui manquait.
Rocky accepte finalement d'affronter Creed,
conscient cependant que battre le champion
du monde relève de l'impossible. Son
objectif : tenir la distance. Autrement dit, réussir là où Wepner a échoué : être debout quand la
cloche retentira. Tenir les quinze rounds.
Rocky est à mille lieues du personnage de brute
épaisse que certaines caricatures ont contribué à
forger. C'est au contraire un personnage sensible,
attaché à des principes forts et
conscient de ses limites.
Il semblait avoir fait une croix sur
la quête du bonheur. Et pourtant,
il aura suffi d'un adversaire à battre et de
l'amour d'une femme pour réveiller sa passion.
Mais si on devait dresser le portrait
philosophique de Rocky Balboa,
qu'est-ce que ça donnerait ? Quelles sont les
philosophies qui influencent, sans qu'il le sache,
la vision du monde de Rocky ? C'est ce que je
vous propose de découvrir dans cet épisode.
Rocky est un boxeur. Son principal instrument
de travail, c'est son corps. Un corps qu'il
doit endurcir et discipliner par
de longues séances d'entraînement,
jusqu'à en acquérir la maîtrise totale.
Mais la boxe, ce n'est pas seulement une
affaire de physique. C'est également une
affaire de mental. Encaisser les coups,
supporter l'épuisement, continuer à avancer
quand tout nous pousse à capituler : c'est ça
qui fait la marque des grands combattants.
A l'instar de Wepner, la technique de Rocky
est rudimentaire. Ce qui le distingue des
autres boxeurs, c'est son incroyable capacité
de résistance et sa ténacité hors du commun. Une
qualité que lui reconnaîtra même le plus granitique
de ses adversaires, Ivan Drago, lorsqu'il dira, le
regard inquiet, que Rocky n'est pas un humain.
Chez Rocky, corps et esprit sont en étroite
relation. Lorsqu'il a décidé de battre son
adversaire, aucun coup ne saurait venir
à bout de sa détermination. A l'inverse,
quand son moral est en berne, quand le doute
s'empare de lui, ou quand il ne se sent plus
soutenu par ceux qu'il aime, son corps perd de sa
force et de sa vitalité. Comme le souligne Adrian,
l'étalon italien ne bat pas ses adversaires avec
ses muscles, mais avec son cœur.
Quand Rockyest sur le ring, c'est son âme qui boxe.
L'idée que le corps et l'esprit constituent
deux entités en interaction l'une
avec l'autre a été développée par un
philosophe du XVIIème siècle : Spinoza.
Pour Spinoza, tout ce qui affecte l'esprit
affecte galement le corps. Et tout ce
qui affecte le corps affecte également
l'esprit. Pour le dire simplement, chez
Spinoza, corps et esprit ne font qu'un.
La vision de Spinoza s'oppose à la théorie de Descartes, selon laquelle
corps et esprit constitueraient deux réalités indépendantes. Pour Spinoza au contraire,
nos pensées influencent notre état physique,
de même que notre état physique influence nos
pensées. On appelle cela le monisme.
C'est ce qui fait que lorsqu'un événement
heureux nous arrive, nous pouvons sentir
l'énergie monter dans notre corps,
même si nous n'avons pas dormi depuis 24 heures.
Ou qu'à l'inverse, un événement tragique produira
en nous une sensation d'abattement, réduisant à néant notre vitalité physique.
Pour Spinoza, les affects agissent
parallèlement sur notre vie psychique
et sur notre vie corporelle. Un affect
de joie augmentera notre volonté, tandis
qu'un affect de tristesse la diminuera.
Rocky puise sa force dans sa sensibilité.
Sa combativité est le reflet de ses affects.
Quand Adrian plonge dans le coma,
Rocky est dévasté. Il cesse l'entraînement et
renonce à combattre Creed. Les interventions de son
entraîneur Mickey n'y changeront rien : Rocky n'a
plus la volonté. Mais lorsqu'Adrian se réveille
et lui demande de gagner, Rocky est galvanisé.
Son corps est tributaire de ses sentiments.
On entend souvent dire que sur le ring, c'est le
mental qui fait la différence. Pour Spinoza, c'est
à la fois vrai et faux. C'est vrai, parce que la
volonté est ce qui met notre corps en action. Mais
c'est faux dans la mesure où notre volonté est avant
tout l'expression de nos ressources physiques.
Lorsque Rocky troque sa bière pour des œufs crus,
lorsqu'il court pendant des kilomètres ou qu'il se
refuse aux avances d'Adrian, ce n'est pas
seulement pour régénérer son corps,
mais aussi : pour fortifier sa volonté. Parce qu'il
sait que de sa vitalité physique dépend sa vitalité
mentale, et que de l'énergie dilapidée, c'est
quelques grammes de détermination en moins.
Le corps et l'esprit de Rocky ne sont pas
séparés. Ils sont soudés l'un à l'autre par
la volonté dont tout son être est animé.
Comme la grande majorité des boxeurs amateurs
à son poque, Rocky est pauvre. Sa survie matérielle, il la doit aux quelques dizaines de
dollars qu'il empoche par combat, et au
maigre salaire que lui verse Tony Gazzo,
un usurier pour lequel il travaille
comme recouvreur de dettes.
Rocky vit dans un appartement miteux de
Philadelphie. Des feuilles de journal
recouvrent les trous de son canapé, mais pas ceux
de ses t-shirts. Pour autant, Rocky ne semble
pas souffrir de cette situation d'indigence. Il
l'assume, et même, il la cultive. Quand il invite
Adrian chez lui et qu'elle souhaite téléphoner à son
frère pour lui dire où elle est, Rocky lui répond
qu'il a jeté son téléphone, car c'est une source de
dérangement. Pour la fausse patte de Philadelphie,
la liberté passe avant le confort matériel.
En cela, Rocky rejoint les prescriptions
d'une école philosophique de
l'Antiquité : les Cyniques.
Le plus célèbre des Cyniques, c'est Diogène de
Sinope. Vêtu d'un manteau sale et troué, rejetant
le superflu, Diogène arpentait les rues d'Athènes muni de son bâton et dormait dans une jarre.
Lorsqu'un jour, il vit un petit garçon se servir
de ses mains pour boire l'eau d'une fontaine,
il jeta son écuelle, honteux de s'être rendu
compte qu'un enfant venait de lui donner une
leçon de sagesse. L'aspiration des cyniques, c'est
le détachement à l'égard des biens matériels.
Dire que Rocky vit heureux dans le dénuement
serait abusif. Ses yeux ne trompent pas quand
il regarde sa photo de lui enfant, et qu'il
fait le constat dans son miroir de son échec
social. Ou quand il s'emporte violemment
contre son entraîneur à cause des jugements
et du mépris dont il est l'objet.
Mais le fait est que pour Rocky,
l'essentiel ne réside pas dans l'abondance,
mais dans la fierté d'une vie simple et
conforme à ses principes. C'est ce qu'il échoueraà
transmettre à son protégé , Tommy Gunn, lorsqu'il
le mettra en garde contre les motivations matérielles de son nouveau mécène, un personnage
largement inspiré de Don King, un promoteur
de combats connu pour son appétit du gain.
Rocky refuse les honneurs. A propos de la statue à
son effigie érigée sur le parvis du musée d'art
de Philadelphie, il se contentera de dire que
tant qu'elle sera là, il y aura un perchoir pour
les pigeons. Au-delà de l'ironie, c'est une manière
de désacraliser sa personne et d'aller à l'encontre
des conventions qui fondent l'attribution de
la valeur sur des critères superficiels.
A l'image de Diogène qui demanda qu'on jette son
cadavre au lieu de l'enterrer, montrant par là
son imperméabilité aux honneurs, et son refus
d'un hommage aussi futile qu'injustifié.
Le mot "cynique" vient du grec ancien "kuon"
qui signifie "chien". Bien que les sources diffèrent
à ce sujet, le choix du mot "cynique" pour
qualifier cette philosophie vient du fait que Diogène
revendiquait de vivre comme un chien, c'est-à-dire sans égard vis-à-vis des conventions.
Pour Diogène, les chiens sont supérieurs aux hommes, parce qu'ils ne
s'encombrent pas d'artifices, et parce qu'ils ne
s'attribuent pas une valeur qu'ils n'ont pas.
Rocky pense la même chose. Son ami le plus
proche, c'est son bulldog : Butkus. Butkus
qui fut le véritable chien de Sylvester Stallone,
et qui accompagnera l'acteur durant ses années
difficiles. Peu avant sa revanche contre Apollo
Creed, Rocky confiera à Butkus : "Parfois,
j'aimerais être un chien". Une allusion implicite
au fait qu'en anglais, "underdog" (littéralement
: sous-chien) est le mot par lequel on désigne
le combattant qu'on ne s'attend pas à voir gagner,
celui en qui personne ne croit.
Et c'est encore un chien qui accompagnera
Rocky dans son dernier combat, un
chien défraîchi dont personne ne veut,
et que Rocky baptisera Punchy pour rappeler à son
jeune maître que même à un âge avancé, il nous reste
toujours un dernier combat dans le ventre.
Rocky n'est pas seulement un personnage animé
par la volonté. C'est aussi un personnage
qui a fait de la simplicité et du refus
des honneurs un art de vivre.
L'analyse du personnage de Rocky
resterait incomplète si on occultait une dimension
essentielle de sa personnalité : l'idéalisme.
Enfant des rues, traînant sur les docks avec
sa veste en cuir et sa cigarette à la bouche,
à première vue, Rocky n'incarne pas l'idéal.
Il a conscience d'être perçu comme un voyou,
et semble même gêné d'inspirer la
crainte aux débiteurs de son patron.
Bob le fuit quand il l'aperçoit, car il sait
que la règle en cas de dette non remboursée,
c'est que Rocky lui casse le pouce. Or, Rocky
ne le fera pas. Il désobéira à Tony, prétextant
qu'avec le pouce cassé, il lui sera impossible
de travailler pour rembourser sa dette.
Quand Rocky voit la petite Marie s'acoquiner
avec des loubards, il la soustrait au groupe
pour la raccompagner chez elle et la
gratifie d'une leçon de bonne conduite,
qui n'aura pas les effets escomptés.
La trahison de Tommy Gunn sera l'un de ses plus
grands coups durs. Après l'avoir recueilli chez
lui et l'avoir entraîné, après lui avoir offert
la chambre de son fils et le pendentif que lui
avait donné Mickey, Tommy le délaissera pour une
décapotable et une promesse d'aller au titre.
La déception de Rocky sera la hauteur de la
pureté de son idéal. La méchanceté et la
corruption ne font pas partie de son
logiciel de fonctionnement. Et lorsqu'il y
est confronté, c'est l'incompréhension.
L'univers mental dans lequel évolue Rocky, c'est
le monde idéal des essences platoniciennes.
Platon concevait le monde comme la projection en
mouvement d'objets éternels qu'il nommait :
lesessences. Une essence, c'est la version
pure et immatérielle de tout ce qui est.
Dans le monde des essences, la corruption
n'existe pas, l'imperfection n'existe pas,
puisque l'imperfection est le
propre du monde matériel.
Ainsi, pour Platon, le mal n'est rien d'autre que la dégradation du
bien. Le mal n'est rien d'autre qu'un accident.
En cela, Platon partageait la conception
de son maître Socrate, qui disait :
"Nul ne fait le mal volontairement".
Selon cette idée, le mal ne peut pas
être délibérément choisi par l'être
humain, car l'homme possèderait en
lui un désir naturel d'aller vers le bien.
Dire que nul ne fait le mal volontairement,
c'est dire que celui qui fait le mal croit
en réalité faire le bien, et donc que le mal
constitue simplement : une erreur de jugement.
Rocky n'arrive pas à concevoir que l'on puisse
choisir le mal. Il n'arrive pas à concevoir que
Tommy ait pu le trahir en conscience. Pour lui,
il ne peut s'agir que d'une erreur de
jugement ou d'un malentendu. Plus pragmatique,
Adrian fera sortir Rocky de son rêve
platonicien en lui rappelant que Tommy
n'est pas lui, car il n'a pas son cœur.
Rocky voit le bon en chaque personne.
Il refuse de céder à loi de la corruption qui
régit les comportements dans le monde de
la matière. Dans l'opus final, il retrouvera
la petite Marie à qui il avait fait la morale
trente ans plus tôt. Une adolescente devenue
mère à qui il proposera du travail pour qu'elle
puisse élever son fils dans de meilleures
conditions, et pour laquelle il n'hésitera
pas à donner une autre leçon, de politesse cette
fois-ci, à un détracteur un peu trop grossier.
Platon, dont le nom signifie "le large
d'épaules", était adepte du pancrace,
un sport de combat antique dans lequel tous les
coups ou presque étaient autorisés. Platon qui
nous rappelle ainsi que la sagesse n'est
pas incompatible avec le goût du combat,
et que dans un monde matériel corrompu, il faut
parfois jouer des poings pour défendre le bien.
Volonté, simplicité, idéalisme : tels sont
les maîtres-mots de la philosophie de Rocky.
Un personnage qui s'est battu contre le mépris et
la fatalité, et qui nous rappelle que la vie est
d'abord un combat. Un combat où l'important n'est
pas de frapper le plus fort, mais de se relever
et de toujours avancer. D'encaisser, sans jamais
flancher. Qui nous rappelle que chaque seconde est
une opportunité, et que le combat n'est pas
terminé tant que la cloche n'a pas sonné...